David Boder: [In English] Geneva, Switzerland, Monday, August the 26th. The interviewee is a young man, Hamburger, nineteen years old.
David Boder: [auf deutsch] Also Herr Hamburger, was ist Ihr voller Name und wo sind Sie geboren und was tun Sie jetzt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich heiße Ludwig Hamburger,
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... geboren aus Polen ....
David Boder: In welcher Stadt?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Katowitz.
David Boder: Oh.
Ludwig Hamburger: Alt – neunzehn (19) Jahre.
David Boder: Sie sind neunzehn (19) Jahre alt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Jawohl.
David Boder: Nun dann sagen Sie, Herr Hamburger, wo waren Sie wenn der Krieg anfing und was hat Ihnen dann passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, das war eine lange Geschichte, ....
David Boder: Ja, bitte erzählen Sie, wir haben Zeit.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es ist so, am Anfang des Krieges war alles richtig.
David Boder: Sie können jiddisch reden, wenn Sie wollen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja. Also da war alles fein und richtig. Ich war in Katowitz mit meinen Eltern zusammen und dann ist das Schrecklichste gekommen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Man hat mich getrennt von meine lieben Eltern ....
Ludwig Hamburger: .... und ich bin allein geblieben.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Von dort bin ich geschickt worden in das Konzentrationslager Auschwitz und nachher nach Buchenwald. In Buchenwald habe ich erlebt das Schlimmste, aber auch das Beste. Ich bin befreit worden dort.
Ludwig Hamburger: Von amerikanische Dritte Armee.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und dann bin ich gekommen nach Schweiz.
David Boder: All right. Nun.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und dann .............. (schluchzt)
David Boder: Also, wollen wir dann wieder zurück gehen. Erzählen Sie, wie, wo und unter was für Bedingungen hat man Sie von Ihren Eltern getrennt? Wo war das? Wann war das und so weiter?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war .... in der schönsten Zeit im Sommer.
David Boder: Also weiter.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war im Sommer. Die Nazis haben im Sinne gehabt alle Juden auszurotten. Wir sind gesammelt worden auf einem großen ... auf einem großen Platz; gesammelt mit meinen Eltern und meiner einzigen Schwester und dann getrennt worden.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Gesondert Männer...
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir ... ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Gesondert Männer, gesondert Frauen und Kinder.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Kinder ..... die haben das Schlimmste erlebt.
Ludwig Hamburger: Man hat sie einfach gemordet, man hat sie vernichtet – wie die ärgsten Tier hat man uns behandelt.
David Boder: Wie, waren Sie unter die Kinder?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein. Ich war schon mit die Jugendliche.
David Boder: Sie waren mit den Jugendlichen? Haben Sie ...
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich habe alles beobachtet und ich ...
David Boder: Was haben Sie gesehen? Erzählen Sie mir alles was sie gesehen haben.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich habe es gesehen eine Tat, ich habe es selber mit gemacht , in Ober Schlesien im Ghetto.
David Boder: Also ich will, dass Sie mit erzählen wie es in Katowitz war.
Ludwig Hamburger: In Katowitz wurden wir versammelt auf dem großen, auf einem großen Platz ...
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... und da hat man geteilt in Männer, Kinder , Jugendliche, Frauen .....
David Boder: Und Sie waren mit ....
Ludwig Hamburger: Den Jugendlichen.
David Boder: Ja. Waren unter den Jugendlichen gemischt Mädchen und Jungen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein, nur Jungen.
David Boder: Nur Jungen, ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und dann hat man (unverständlich) ins Arbeitslager. Und die Älteren haben sie nach Auschwitz gebracht – verbrannt.
David Boder: Die Älteren hat man geschickt .... als wo sind Ihre Eltern geblieben?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, ich habe meine Eltern nicht mehr gesehen, seit neunzehn hundert ein und vierzig, seit damals.
David Boder: Seit damals, wo Sie auf den Platz aufgerufen wurden?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Haben Sie versucht Ihre Eltern zu suchen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Jawohl.
David Boder: Wo haben Sie sie gesucht?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich habe nachgefragt mit OSE in der Schweiz, mit den Flüchtlingshilfe und danach auch noch mit dem Roten ...mit dem internationalen Roten Kreuz.
David Boder: Sie haben nachgefragt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja, aber .....
Ludwig Hamburger: Keine Nachricht.
David Boder: Also man hat Sie in ein Arbeitslager genommen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Jawohl.
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie, wie und wo und was ist dann passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich bin damals ins Arbeitslager gekommen – als Kind – vierzehn (14) Jahre noch.
David Boder: Ja. Und haben die gewusst, dass Sie vierzehn Jahre alt sind?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein.
David Boder: Was haben sie gewusst?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben uns alle ausgegeben, wir sind älter.
David Boder: Warum?
Ludwig Hamburger: Weil als vierzehn (14) jähriges Kind kann einem keiner zwingen in die Arbeit.
David Boder: Oh, so haben Sie alle gesagt, dass sie älter sind?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben uns alle ausgegeben, als wir sind älter.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gesagt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich habe gesagt, ich bin 16 Jahre alt.
David Boder: Ja. Und dann?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und dann hat man mich zu einem gewissen Arbeitsdetail verbannt, sehr schwer für mich.
David Boder: Was haben Sie getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: Im Steinbruch habe ich gearbeitet.
David Boder: Ja? Wie haben Sie gearbeitet im Steinbruch?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Steine waren einfach grösser als ich!
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und mit Stöcken, die Schlägerei und das Schreierei war den ganzen Tag. Wir haben 16 Stunden dabei gearbeitet.
David Boder: Und war für Werkzeug haben Sie gehabt? Womit haben Sie die Steine gebrochen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Mit der Hand, also nein, wir haben sie getragen.
David Boder: Oh, Sie haben die Steine getragen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Getragen ...
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und die SS, the Garde, die haben uns getrieben wie Hunde, wie Tiere ..... geschlagen. Dass mussten sie tun, sie konnten nur schlagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und da haben wir sechzehn(16) Stunden gearbeitet am Tag – man kann sagen: ohne Essen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben täglich bekommen ein Stück Brot, das war von altem Mehl und man kann das einfach nicht ertragen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und Wasser .....
Ludwig Hamburger: .... und einen halben ( ½ ) Liter Suppe.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Das haben wir bekommen.
David Boder: Ja. Und das war wo?
Ludwig Hamburger: Das war in Auschwitz, am Anfang in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja. In Auschwitz, ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Und sind Ihre Eltern mit Ihnen zusammen nach Auschwitz gefahren?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, wir sind zusammen gefahren mit dem Wagen, hm, mit ....
David Boder: Mit der Eisenbahn.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... mit dem Eisenbahnzug und dann in Auschwitz wurden wir getrennt?
David Boder: Ah, Sie sind in Auschwitz getrennt worden. Und was hat man Ihnen gesagt, wenn man Sie von Ihren Eltern getrennt hat?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein, die hatten, die haben gar nichts erzählt. Wir haben Angst gehabt ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... etwas zu sagen. Wir haben gesehen die Männer ....
Ludwig Hamburger: .... mit die Stöcken, mit die Hunde und alles, und .....
David Boder: Was für Hunde?
Ludwig Hamburger: Also, ..... ganz große Hunde , die heißen ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ...... Schäferhunde.
David Boder: Die Schäferhunde. Warum haben sie Hunde gehabt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie haben .... das kann man nicht sagen. Sie waren ..... einfach immer gegen uns. Weil sie sich die Hän.de nicht schmutzig haben machen wollen, dafür haben sie die Hunde gebracht.
David Boder: Aha. Und was haben die Hunde getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es waren speziell trainierte Hunde ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... gegen Menschen. Und wenn die haben bemerkt einen Sträflingsanzug oder einen Juden aus einem, aus der Reihe, dann sind sie sofort auf ihn raufgesprungen und haben ihn zerreißen wollen.
David Boder: Aha. Nun waren die Hunde nicht an Ketten? Waren die Hunde nicht ....
Ludwig Hamburger: Oh ja, die waren an Ketten, aber sie haben sie ausgelassen, wenn eine Jude irgendwie ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... (unverständlich).
David Boder: Nun, Sie wurden von Ihren Eltern getrennt ..... in Auschwitz und Sie haben sie nie wieder gesehen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein.
David Boder: Und wie lange waren Sie in Auschwitz?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Auschwitz war ich zwei (2) Monate lang. Dann bin ich gekommen auf ein Lager .....Blechhammer. Das ist nicht weit von Auschwitz – Blechhammer.
David Boder: Blechhammer.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das war ein Abteil von Auschwitz.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das war auch unter Auschwitz.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann habe ich gearbeitet bei Eisen ...
David Boder: Was haben sie getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben Schienen getragen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ganz lange Schienen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Größtenteils Jugendliche – vierzehn (14) Jahre.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dort bin ich fast umgekommen.
David Boder: Was meinen Sie mit umgekommen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich bin gekommen mit zwanzig Jungen ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... von meiner Stadt.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und nur drei (3) sind geblieben.
David Boder: Nur drei (3) sind geblieben?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nach vier (4) Monaten.
David Boder: Und was ist mit den Anderen passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Arbeit war zu schwer.
David Boder: Und was ist ihnen passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie sind einfach zusammen gebrochen ..... bei der Arbeit sind sie zusammen gebrochen.
David Boder: Und was hat man mit ihnen getan später?
Ludwig Hamburger: Weg geschmissen wie eine Sack.
David Boder: Also das macht keinen Sinn! Erzählen Sie mir die Details,. Zum Beispiel, was soll das heißen, einer ist zusammen gebrochen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Arbeit war zu schwer und man hat sie geschlagen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir hatten nichts zu essen. Wir hatten nichts zu essen gehabt und wir haben sechzehn Stunden gearbeitet täglich.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und die Jugendlichen (unverständlich – beide reden) Und alle waren ...
David Boder: Nun was ist denen passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Bei der Arbeit ....
David Boder: Nehmen Sie, zum Beispiel einen Jungen, an den Sie sich erinnern und sagen Sie mir was, was hat ihm passiert? Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Der Junge hat einmal beim Tragen der Schiene .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ...... da hat er gesagt, er hat Kopfschmerzen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und er hat sich runter gebeugt und wir haben gedenkt, er sucht etwas und er hat weiter gesucht und wir haben zu ihm gesagt: „Warum stehst nicht auf?“
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und wir haben keine Antwort mehr bekommen.
David Boder: Nun.
Ludwig Hamburger: Da haben wir ihn angeschaut und er ist liegen geblieben.
David Boder: Er ist liegen geblieben? Erzählen Sie mir, was hat man mit ihm gemacht?
Ludwig Hamburger: Man hat ..... die SS Männer sind zugelaufen und wir wollten, dass sie ihn auf die Seite legen und ins Lager mitnehmen. Aber sie haben gesagt: „Lasst ihn in Ruhe. Er hat die Arbeit nicht gemacht und das Gleiche wird Euch passieren.“
David Boder: Nun also, ist der Junge gestorben oder was hat ihm passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Er ist gestorben.
David Boder: Er ist gestorben. Nun also weiter. Und das war wo?
Ludwig Hamburger: Das war in Blechhammer.
David Boder: In Blechhammer?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun wie lange waren Sie in Blechhammer?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich Blechhammer war ich zwei (2) Jahre.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann ist gekommen die Evakuation.
David Boder: In Blechhammer waren Sie zwei (2) Jahre?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Erzählen Sie mir, wie ist dort ein Tag vergangen. Wann sind Sie aufgestanden und alles?
Ludwig Hamburger: Also jeden Tag sind wir geweckt geworden um vier (4) oder halb vier ( ½ 4) .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... bei dem Block Ältesten und zum Appell.
Ludwig Hamburger: Der Appell hat gedauert einmal ..... wenn Einer ist später gekommen, dann hat er gedauert länger. Dann ist der Lager Kommandant gekommen mit dem Appell Führer und der hat den Appell genommen und wenn er den Bericht bekommen hat, dann ist alles gut.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann nach dem Appell sind wir wieder in den Block gekommen und da haben wir heißes Wasser bekommen; das haben sie genannt Kaffee.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann hat man uns ein Stückchen Brot gegeben.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das trockene Brot ....
Ludwig Hamburger: ... und dann sofort zur Arbeit.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Aber im Winter, wie im Sommer angezogen waren wir, kann man sagen, in nichts. Wir haben die gestreiften Anzüge gehabt mit Holz-Sandalen, keine Schuhe. Ich habe so gelitten damals. Ich habe mir selber mein Hemd müssen waschen, ich habe kein Anderes gehabt.
David Boder: Also das Hemd waschen, das kann man tun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war Winter.
David Boder: Aha, ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Da habe ich mein Hemd gewaschen und dann bin ich ohne Hemd zu der Arbeit gegangen, nur mit einer dünnen Jacke.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das einzige Gute war, wir haben den Mut nicht verloren.
David Boder: Sie haben den Mut nicht verloren – wie ist das gekommen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich hab immer im Sinn gehabt meine Eltern.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wie ich ein Kind war ..... als Kind haben meine Eltern mir verschiedene Geschichten von Märchenbüchern vorgelesen oder ich habe selber gelesen.
David Boder: Was für Geschichten?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, ich habe immer selber gelesen, ja den Mut darf man nicht verlieren und ich habe immer meine Mutter gehört und an meine Mutter gedacht.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Hie und da war ich schon lebensmüde. Das kann kein Mensch aushalten. Einmal habe ich bekommen ein und zwanzig (21) Schläge ..... für nichts. Ein SS Mann hat mich angehalten.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann hat er mich gefragt: „Wieviel ist drei (3) mal sieben (7).“ Ich habe gesagt: „Ein und zwanzig (21).“ Dann hat mich (unverständlich) und hat mir ein und zwanzig (21) Schläge gegeben.
David Boder: Warum?
Ludwig Hamburger: Das kann nicht erklärt werden. Er hat mich einfach gefragt und gesagt: „Bub, kannst Du rechnen?“ Ich hab gesagt: „Jawohl.“ Er hat gesagt: „Wieviel ist drei (3) mal sieben (7)?“ Hab ich ihm geantwortet und er hat gesagt: „Komm her!“ und dann hat er mir ein und zwanzig (21) Schläge gegeben.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind hinaus gegangen zu der Arbeit – hat geregnet. Der SS Mann war schön warm angezogen für Winter ..... und wir waren verfroren, hungrig. (unverständlich, starkes Rauschen im Band).
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich habe einen Freund gehabt im Lager und jeden Tag, wenn wir uns gesehen haben, wir haben gesagt „Auf Wiedersehen“. Niemand von uns hat gewusst, ob wir uns wiedersehen. Die Aufsicht und (unverständlich) war alles Mörderer. Das war das Mieseste von Deutschland, ja. Die haben uns geschlagen bei der Arbeit ..... für das Kleinste, sie haben uns geschlagen. Sie haben gesagt, wir sind Saboteure.
David Boder: Ah hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und viele Freunde, viele unserer Kameraden haben verloren ihr Leben. Wenn sie haben eine Schraube verloren, wenn sie haben was niederfallen lassen, wenn es zu schwer gewesen, hat man gesagt Sabotage und ... ermordet.
David Boder: Und wo haben Sie gearbeitet dann?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir die Gefangenen haben überall gearbeitet. Hm, das war ..... man hat uns die schwerste Arbeit machen lassen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Beim Bunker graben.
Ludwig Hamburger: Beim Schützengraben.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ausgrabung machen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Beim Minen graben.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir waren bei den Gefährlichsten (unverständlich).
David Boder: Und das hat wie lange gedauert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Das hat gedauert so lange bis wir evakuiert worden.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie mir von der Evakuation.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Russen haben sich bewältigt.
David Boder: Genähert, ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und es ist gekommen, wir müssen alle evakuiert werden. Das war am ein und zwanzigsten (21.) Dezember.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war sehr kalt, Schnee. Und auf einmal kommt der Befehl .....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: „Alle antreten“!
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir gehen, wohin? Das weiß niemand. Wir sind aufgestanden und man hat jeder eine Decke ....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... eine dünne Decke, ein Brot, ein Stück Butter ....
David Boder: Das war Butter?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, das einzige Mal! Margarine.
David Boder: Margarine?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ha, ha ..... wir haben gesagt Butter .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir kennen keinen anderen Ausdruck!
Ludwig Hamburger: Damals hat es wie Butter geschmeckt ... damals.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind raus gegangen, der Schnee war ganz hoch ..... Wind, Frost. Wir sind rausgegangen vier tausend (4000) Mann von Blechhammer.
David Boder: Na, wie sagen Sie Blechhammer?
Ludwig Hamburger: Von Blechhammer.
David Boder: Blechhammer. Jas, nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: In die Richtung Gleiwitz.
David Boder: Was? Gleiwitz?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, in Ober Schlesien.
David Boder: Zu Fuß marschiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die ganze Zeit marschiert.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und so die ersten paar Stunden waren erträglich. Wir sind gelaufen. Etwas weiter, dann war es schlimmer, wir sind die Nacht durch marschiert. Aber es war auch Glück.
David Boder: Die Nacht sind Sie marschiert, ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind die Nacht durch marschiert. Oft war, wenn sie nicht mehr können haben, haben sie uns reingetrieben in eine Scheune .... in eine Scheune, vier tausend Mann.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war wirklich schrecklich. Die SS Männer waren rund herum und bewaffnet stark. Man hat uns reingejagt, es war sehr wenig Platz, so einer ist rauf gerückt auf die, die Anderen. Morgens wenn wir sind heraus gegangen, da waren viele Kameradem geblieben.
David Boder: Was heißt geblieben?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir selber haben sie zertreten. Mit einzige, einer, mit eigenen Beinen haben wir unsere Brüder zu Tode getreten.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Jeden Tag war es schlimmer. Das Brot hat geendet, kein Wasser. Ich wollte einmal etwas Wasser bei einem Brunnen trinken, das war bei Raczibor.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Da ist ein SS Mann gekommen, der hat mich mit dem Gewicht über die Schulter gehauen, dass ich einfach total umgefallen bin.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Für ein kleines bisserl Wasser!
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind weiter gegangen, dann sind wir alle gekommen nach Gross-Rosen. Der Weg nach Gross-Rosen ...
David Boder: Wo ist Gross-Rosen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Bei Breslau.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es ist der Weg von Blechhammer nach Gross-Rosen – das war der Weg von viele Tote. Wir sind rein gekommen nach Gross-Rosen ... von vier tausend (4000) Mann sind wir angekommen zwei hundert vier und achtzig (284).
David Boder: Was heißt das?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir waren ....
David Boder: Was ist mit den Anderen passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Erschossen.
David Boder: Aber ....
Ludwig Hamburger: Und in der Scheune ..... in der Scheune haben wir uns selbst zu Tod getreten.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Also das Brot ... wir sind gelaufen sieben (7) Tage.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das Brot hat uns genügt .... genügt für drei (3) Tage.
David Boder: Hm, und dann ..... dann haben sie nicht mehr ....
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann haben wir nichts mehr bekommen.
David Boder: Ja, nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es ist wirklich schwer zu glauben, wir glauben es selber nicht mehr, wieso kann man sieben (7) Tage auf einem Brot aushalten? Ohne Wasser. Es war ein Glück, dass wir Schnee haben gehabt. Wir haben .... Schnee gegessen ....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... anstatt Wasser.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind angekommen ....
David Boder: Also erzählen Sie mir von dieser Reise. Sagen Sie in der Nacht haben Sie in einer Scheune geschlafen. Dann sind sie aufgestanden, was hat dann passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann sind wir gelaufen, immer zu Fuß gegangen.
David Boder: Und die SS Männer, die sind auch gegangen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, die SS Männer sind auch gegangen, aber sie haben – die haben sich gewechselt.
David Boder: Was heißt das? Wo sind die Anderen geblieben?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die sind in dem Wagen gefahren.
David Boder: Oh, Sie meinen Einige waren im Wagen, Andere sind zu Fuß gegangen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Was hat während dem Gehen passiert? Erzählen Sie mir einzelne Fälle.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wie wir sind raus gegangen, das waren wir noch guten Mutes, denn wir haben gedacht, dass die Russen nahe sind.
David Boder: Aha.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dass die Befreiung ist da.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben die Schießerei gehört und haben gesagt: „Gott sei Dank, jetzt sind wir wieder frei.“
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Aber dann, wir haben gesehen, dass es immer, immer wieder weniger und ruhiger war und wir sind weiter gegangen und wir haben nichts gesehen und wir sind moralisch total kaputt geworden, wir sind moralisch schlapp geworden.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben nichts mehr geglaubt, die Hoffnung ist verloren gewesen. Wir haben verloren alles. Wir haben gesagt: „Wir waren so nahe, so nahe waren wir schon auf dem Weg zur Befreiung und es war nicht gewesen“. Wir haben gedenkt, das Schicksal wollte dass wir alle drauf gehen.“
David Boder: Ja, nun.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und Viele haben gesagt, ich mach schon, was ich will. Und sie haben das Brot aufgegessen auf dem ersten (1.) Tag. Sie wollten einfach satt sterben.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das Einzige was sie wollten, war sterben als Satte.
David Boder: Hm, nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und .....
David Boder: Sterben als Satte?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun.
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie haben es aufgegessen und sind dann nicht weiter gelaufen. Es war sehr kalt und sie haben gesagt: „Wir können nicht mehr.“ Und sie sind sitzen geblieben. Und die SS Männer haben sie gefragt: „Warum sitzt ihr denn da?“ Und er hat gesagt: „Ich kann nicht mehr.“ Dann hat er ihn erschossen.
David Boder: Er hat den erschossen. Haben Sie das selbst gesehen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Alle habe es selbst gesehen! Der Weg von Blechhammer nach Gross-Rosen war belegt mit tote Leute, alle zehn (10), fünfzehn (15) Meter ein Toter.
David Boder: Nun, und wie sind Sie dann gegangen? Erzählen Sie mir über sich selbst, wie haben Sie das.... wie sind Sie durch?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich habe einen Freund gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind immer miteinander gegangen. Wir haben sich beide aneinander gehalten.
David Boder: Wo ist Ihr Freund jetzt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Der Freund ist hier.
David Boder: Er ist hier, nun also?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben immer den Willen gehabt, damit wir ausgehalten haben. Wir haben gesagt, nein, wie müssen durchhalten. Wir sind schon drei (3) Jahre hier, drei (3)Jahre haben wir es gemacht, wir schaffen es noch ein (1) Jahr. Wir werden es aushalten, denn wir haben es so lange durch gemacht, wir werden es aushalten bis zum Ende.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wie der Eine, der Andere hat es immer (unverständlich – Rauschen im Tonband)
Ludwig Hamburger: Das Brot haben wir rationiert, wir haben sich gewaschen mit Schnee.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Viele von uns hatten die Hände abgefroren und auch die Beine. Wir haben unsere Hände und unsere Beine tagtäglich mit Schnee gewaschen. Wir haben gewusst noch von zu Hause, das ist das Einzige was gegen Frost und Erfrieren hilft.
David Boder: Gegen was?
Ludwig Hamburger: Gegen Frost.
David Boder: Und gegen was?
Ludwig Hamburger: Erfrieren.
David Boder: Nun.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben .... wir haben sich gefreut zusammen. Wir haben sich gegenseitig ..... wir haben sich erzählt Geschichten von zu Hause.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: So war der Weg ..... durch den ganzen Weg haben wir sich erzählt und wir haben gehabt Gedenken gehabt, von der Familie gehabt.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben sich erinnert an zu Hause, an die Schule und alles und wir haben gesagt: „Das ist unmöglich, dass das alles ist für immer vergangen. Es wird bestimmt wieder kommen.“
Ludwig Hamburger: Und so sind wir nach Gross-Rosen gegangen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: In Gross-Rosen, das war das Schlimmste, was wir haben mitgemacht.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war .... es war kein KZ.
David Boder: Was?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war kein KZ, kein KZ hat so gut ausgesehen.
David Boder: Was ist ein KZ?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ein Konzentrationslager, ja.
David Boder: Ja, hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war einfach nicht auszuhalten – noch schlimmer wie Auschwitz.
David Boder: Zum Beispiel?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir wurden reingejagt vier tausend (4000) Mann in ein Haus von ungefähr ein hundert fünfzig (150) Meter Quadrat
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Einer auf dem Anderen ist gelegen, gesetzt und gestanden und nichts zu essen bekommen. Überhaupt nichts!
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Morgens um vier (4) Uhr bis zehn (10) Uhr abends sind wir draußen gestanden – Appell – ohne Bewegung.
David Boder: Ja. Warum? Was war ..... wieso hat der Appell so lange gedauert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war ein Vernichtungslager, direkt für eine Art von Vernichtung.
David Boder: Nun erzählen Sie weiter, zum Beispiel, sie sind raus gekommen, wo haben sie sich dann hingestellt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Da waren so viele SS Männer.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das Schlimmste kann man sagen, was ich hab durch gelebt.
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie sind auf einmal rein in den Block ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... und mit die Stöcke haben sie angefangen zu schlagen und zu schreien „Appell“.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind gelaufen, wir sind raus gegangen. Da haben die angefangen zu zählen. Wenn hat Einer gefehlt oder Einer ist ein paar Minuten spät gekommen oder Einer ist nicht gerade gestanden .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... und es war immer so, dass niemand gerade gestanden ist.
David Boder: Nun.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann mussten wir stehen zwei (2) Stunden für jeden Mann.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben einmal ... wind sind einmal vier und zwanzig (24) Stunden gestanden ohne Bewegung, das ist ohne ...
David Boder: Tag und Nacht?
Ludwig Hamburger: Einen Tag und Nacht, weil Drei (3)im Bett liegen geblieben sind. Sie konnten nicht mehr .....
David Boder: Nun.
Ludwig Hamburger: Für vier und zwanzig (24) Stunden.
David Boder: Was heißt „liegen geblieben“? Sind sie ohnmächtig geworden oder was?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die haben keine Kräfte mehr zum Stehen gehabt.
David Boder: Nun und was ist passiert?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben gesagt: „Also ihr könnt alles tun was ihr wollt mit mir, ich habe keine Kräfte.“
David Boder: Nun, was haben die getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie wurden tot geschlagen im Block und wir mussten stehen vier und zwanzig (24) ...
David Boder: Sie wurden was?
Ludwig Hamburger: Tot geschlagen. Nicht nur ....
David Boder: Was soll das heißen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Mit Stöcke.
David Boder: Wer hat das getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: Der Block-Ältesten.
David Boder: War der ein Jude?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: In Auschwitz, in Gross-Rosen .....
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... da waren die „Grünen“ – so haben wir gesagt. Mit einem grünen Dreieck. Berufsverbrecher.
David Boder: Die Berufsverbrecher. Die waren die Block-Ältesten.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die waren für fünfzehn (15) Jahre, zwanzig (20) Jahre in den Konzentrationslagern.
David Boder: Im Gefängnis und sie haben ..... (beide sprechen)
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, ja, im Gefängnis. Und dann sind sie gekommen ... und die Schlägerei ....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... und wenn so ein Block Ältester, so ein Capo hat zugeschlagen, ob er ein Jude war, ein Tscheche oder ein Pole oder eine andere Nationalität, dann hat er eine Auszeichnung bekommen, dann hat er ein Brot dafür bekommen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich habe mitgemacht einmal so einen Fall, es war in Auschwitz.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind raufgegangen in den Steinbruch.
Ludwig Hamburger: Damals war es so, dass jeder SS Mann, der einen Gefangenen tot geschlagen hat ....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: hat fünf und zwanzig (25), eh, ..... Mark, Reichsmark erhalten dann und fünf Tage Urlaub.
David Boder: Also warum hat er dann nicht jeden Tag wen tot geschlagen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Da musste er einen Grund dafür .....
David Boder: Oh, musste er .....
Ludwig Hamburger: Er musste einen gewissen Grund haben. Da hat er abgemacht mit dem Capo .....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Bei der Arbeit haben wir einen Zaun gehabt von ..... von Sand geschüttet .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... bis da können wir gehen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wer überschreitet diese Grenze wird erschossen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Da hat der SS Mann mit dem Capo so abgemacht, dass der Capo bekommt ein Paket Tabak .....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... dass er einen Juden raus schickt oder einen .....
David Boder: Hm, ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann hat der Capo gesehen ... genommen – ich habe das selber mit gemacht. Ich habe es selber gesehen von fünf (5) Metern. Er hat gerufen einen Jude .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... einen älteren Mann .....
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... und er hat ihm die Hütl herunter genommen .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... und hat es geworfen über den Zaun.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das war noch kein Zaun, da waren nur einige (unverständlich) im Boden .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... und er hat gesagt: „Jetzt geh und hol die Hütl“.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und er hat gesagt: „Wenn ich hole die Hütl jetzt, dann ich beschreite die Grenze und ich werd erschossen.“ So sagt er: „Es ist niemand da, geh und hol es.“
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Er wollte nicht, aber er hat gesagt: „ Wenn Du nicht gehst, erschlag ich Dich.“ Und er hat angefangen zu schlagen. Dann ist er gegangen, der SS Mann war versteckt hinter einem Baum ....
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... und dann wie er beschritten hat den Zaun, hat er ihn sofort erschossen.
David Boder: Oh!
Ludwig Hamburger: Der SS Mann hat gesagt ....
David Boder: Er hat gesagt, dass er ihn erschossen hat weil er hat weglaufen wollen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein. (unverständlich – beide sprechen)
David Boder: Er hat wollen weglaufen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, ja. Und der SS Mann hat dafür 25 Reichsmark und fünf Tage Urlaub bekommen und der Capo hat ein Paket Tabak gehabt.
David Boder: Aha.
Ludwig Hamburger: Also unser Leben war nichts! Die Capos haben sich gespielt mit uns. Sie haben das Brot uns weg genommen, wo wir haben selber wenig gehabt. Sie haben die Suppe weg genommen. Die Suppe mehr Wasser als sonst was, aber wir haben in der Suppe alles gesehen. Ohne das Stückchen Brot und ohne die Suppe waren wir ganz verloren.
David Boder: Nun – also Sie waren dort in diesem Lager, wie hat es geheißen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Gross-Rosen!
David Boder: Gross-Rosen, nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Bei Breslau.
David Boder: Also?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, wir haben gesehen, dass wir hier das Ende abwarten.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Von hier kommen wir nie mehr raus. Das Krematorium hat gebrannt Tag und Nacht.
David Boder: War dort ein Krematorium?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: In jedem Konzentrationslager.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war so. Wenn Einer in Auschwitz ..... in Auschwitz ....
David Boder: Wenn Einer in Auschwitz, ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Auschwitz hat das Krematorium ..... das ist eine unglaubliche Zahl .....vier Millionen (4000000) Menschen verbrannt. Zum größten Teil Juden!
David Boder: We hat das gezählt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Statistik zeigt.
David Boder: Hm, nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die meisten sind Juden, Ungarn ....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... polnische, französische und holländische.
David Boder: Waren dort keine Russen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Auch. Also alle Nationalitäten. Es waren Engländer.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es waren Amerikaner, es waren Schweizer, Schwarze, Rote, alle Farben haben wir da gehabt.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und das Krematorium war Birkenau, es war nicht weit von Auschwitz.
David Boder: Wie weit war es von Auschwitz?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war einige Kilometer von Auschwitz. Dort ist das Krematorium gestanden, es hat Tag und Nacht gebrannt. Also Transporte sind tagtäglich gekommen von vierzig tausend (40000), fünfzig tausend (50000) ..... (unverständlich)
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Von Ungarn ist angekommen ein Transport von sechzig tausend Menschen. Da hat er die Stärksten heraus genommen, also wirklich nur die Stärksten ....
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... und es waren hundert oder zwei hundert und zu den Anderen hat er gesagt: „Ihr geht waschen.“ Niemand hat gewusst was ist los. Alle wurden geteilt in kleine Gruppen – „links, rechts – links, rechts“. In der Mitte ist gestanden ein SS Mann, ein Arzt .... und sie mussten durch gehen, also ausgezogen bis zur Mitte. Mit weißen Handschuhe, angezogen schön und er hat gelacht, wie in einem Theaterspiel .... und mit dem Zeigefinger hat er gezeigt links, rechts, links, rechts. Niemand hat gewusst, was ist links und niemand hat gewusst was rechts heißt.
David Boder: Waren Sie dann dabei?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Leider hat links gemeint durch das Krematorium Tor.
David Boder: Also wohin sind Sie dann von dem ... dem Platz gekommen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Von diesem Platz ....
David Boder: Von dem Lager wo Sie waren, von dem Sie mir eben erzählt haben.
Ludwig Hamburger: Von Gross-Rosen?
David Boder: Ja, von Gross-Rosen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Von Gross-Rosen gingen wir dann nach Buchenwald.
David Boder: Warum?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Russen (unverständlich), die waren schon bei Breslau.
David Boder: Und wie hat man sie transportiert nach Buchenwald?
Ludwig Hamburger: In offene Last-Wagon.
David Boder: In welchem Monat war das?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es war ..... genau ..... am dritten (3.) Februar.
David Boder: Februar! Also in offene Wagon hat man sie transportiert nach Buchenwald?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun wie viele Tage sind Sie gefahren?
Ludwig Hamburger: Also am neunten (9.) Februar waren wir in Buchenwald.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Weimar .....
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: .... da haben wir ein Bombardement mit gemacht.
David Boder: Wieso? Die Amerikaner?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Amerikaner sind gekommen und es war am neunten (9.) Februar als sie haben gebombt Weimar. Wir waren auf der Eisenbahn auf dem .... auf dem Station und die amerikanische Flugzeuge sind rein gekommen..
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben gesagt: „Um Gottes Willen! Wir stehen hier, Menschen, erkennt ihr uns denn nicht?“ Und es hat niemand gewusst, dass wir sind hier.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und sie haben dann angefangen zum Bombardieren, aber zum Glück haben wir nur vier (4) Kameraden verloren.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Also wir glauben es bis heute nicht, die Bomben sind gefallen drei (3) Meter von uns. Bei mir hat eine Bombe zwei (2) Meter vor mir eingeschlagen, und ich war unter der Wolke, unter dem (unverständlich – spricht zu schnell).
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich war ganz verschüttet, aber mir ist nichts passiert.
David Boder: Sie waren am Bahnhof dort?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und dann ist es vorbei gegangen .....
David Boder: Und wo sind die SS geblieben als das anfing?
Ludwig Hamburger: Zusammen mit uns mit uns.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind nach Blechhammer, ..... nach Buchenwald gekommen.
Ludwig Hamburger: In Buchenwald ..... sind wir abends angekommen, hungrig, aber wir haben nichts bekommen, wir haben nicht einmal ein Stück Brot bekommen. Nur ein Brot – das Halbe war für auf der Eisenbahn ..... Und wir sind dann nach Buchenwald, aber es war wieder wie alle anderen Lager, aber eines war besser .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Da waren wir alle Kameraden, da haben wir nur einen Gegner gehabt ....
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... die SS.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Buchenwald .....
David Boder: Wieso? Was für Gegner haben Sie anderswo gehabt?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Auschwitz haben wir die Capos gehabt, die Block Ältesten und die Grünen.
David Boder: Aha.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Berufsverbrecher.
David Boder: Und in Buchenwald?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Buchenwald waren Politische.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und die Politischen haben gesagt, dass wir sind alle Brüder. Es war keine Ausnahme ....
David Boder: Aha.
Ludwig Hamburger: Von Juden nach Arier ...
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... Zwischen Neger und Weiße. Die waren alle dieselben.
David Boder: Zusammen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie waren dieselben Opfer.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben einen Gegner gehabt, die SS.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und gegen die mussten wir kämpfen.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: So ..... das war, das war einen große Erleichterung für uns.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Im Buchenwald Lager,dass wir leben heute, die meisten Jungen, das haben wir zu verdanken dem Lager Ältesten.
David Boder: Wer war das?
Ludwig Hamburger: Er war ein Österreicher.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Der hat sich ganz selbst für uns aufgeopfert .....
David Boder: War er Häftling?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Der hat sich ganz selbst für uns aufgeopfert, um uns zusammen zu halten und uns das Gefühl der Kameradschaft zu geben.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, Buchenwald was einmal auch ein Lager von die Grünen, von den Berufsverbrechern, aber teilweise .....
David Boder: Sie nennen die Grünen die Berufsverbrecher?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann neunzehn hundert und acht und dreißig (1938) da haben die, die Sozialisten die Roten, politische Gefangene gemacht.
David Boder: Schon neunzehn hundert und acht und dreißig (1938)?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und dann war der Kampf. In acht und dreißig waren sie Politische. Dann sind wieder die Grünen gekommen .....
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: .... so dass der Kampf hat sich nicht bis drei und vierzig (43), vier und vierzig (44) sehr stark (unverständlich). Es war das Selbe in Auschwitz. (starker Lärm im Tonband und nicht identifizierbare Stimmen).
David Boder: Und in Buchenwald?
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann .... in vier und vierzig (44) sind die Roten gekommen zur Macht, das heißt die Politischen.
David Boder: Hm. Der Lagerfuehrer?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann war keine Ausnahme von Jude ....
Ludwig Hamburger: .... nach Arier, alle waren die Selbe.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Alle waren wir die Selbe unter der Aufsicht von der SS.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und wir haben nur einen Feind gehabt. Das Essen war genau wie in jedem Konzentrationslager. Appell lange, von vier Stunden und ..... so haben wir das mitgemacht bis am Anfang April. Am Anfang April da haben wir die Nachricht bekommen, dass die Offensive der Alliierten schon ganz in der Nähe.
David Boder: Wie haben Sie diese Nachricht bekommen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben gearbeitet in Rüstungswerke in der Stadt Weimar ...
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: so bei der Arbeit beobachtet man .... wir haben gesehen die Mienen von die Deutschen. Und wir haben gesagt: „Es gibt was Neues!“
David Boder: Ah hm. Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: So war’s .... die Hoffnung hat sich wieder erneut.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Vielleicht .... vielleicht doch, sind wir wirklich die Glücklichen, die noch etwas (unverständlich - Lärm im Tonband). Mit einem Mal – morgens, gehen wir schon nicht mehr raus zu der Arbeit. Wir bleiben alle in unserem Konzentrationslager. Was ist los? Es weiß niemand. Auf einmal hören wir Radios, das heißt wir hatten Lautsprecher in dem Lager.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: „Sämtliche Juden sofort zum Appell auf dem Platz“.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Zu was haben wir alle gewusst – Evakuation.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und so der Lager Älteste hat gesagt .....
David Boder: Lauter.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... gesagt: „Also alle oder niemand.“ Und die Juden sind zusammen mit den Ariern gegangen.
David Boder: Zusammen gegangen? Ja. Haben Sie keine Zeichen getragen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Man hat die Zeichen abgerissen.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und man wusste nicht, wer war Jude, wer war Arier. Das war der Ältestenrat in Buchenwald.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die SS Männer sind runter gekommen und haben angefangen einfach raus zu finden, aber nicht viele haben sie herausgefunden. Und dann haben sie einfach angefangen zu nehmen einfach Arier, Juden, alles was geht. Und wir haben schon gesehen tagtäglich die amerikanischen Jäger haben wir gesehen ... über dem Lager.
David Boder: Die amerikanischen was?
Ludwig Hamburger: Jäger.
David Boder: Was ist das?
Ludwig Hamburger: Flugzeuge, ja.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und die Hoffnung war wieder erneut.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Am elften (11.) April ...
David Boder: Und wohin haben sie die genommen, die sie versammelt haben.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die haben sie einfach raus genommen und evakuiert.
David Boder: Wohin?
Ludwig Hamburger: Niem ... wir haben nicht gewusst.
David Boder: Hm, nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Das Lager hat dann kein Essen mehr bekommen, wegen der Evakuation, weil niemand wollte gehen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: (hustet) Also wir haben sich gesagt, wenn schon ..... ich habe schon mitgemacht eine Evakuation, ich weiß ganz genau, was das ist.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und ich bin dann nicht gegangen für Evakuation. Ich wollte auf keinen Fall mehr machen. Ich sagte mir, ich lebe hier - es ist besser hier ....
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: ... hier zu sterben, als noch eine Evakuation durch zu machen. Was ich habe mit gemacht in Auschwitz, das will ich nie mehr erleben.
David Boder: Nein.
Ludwig Hamburger: Weil die Kraft, die ich in Buchenwald gehabt damals hab, die habe ich leider nie mehr gehabt – ich war schon müde. Den elften (11.) April, das ist der Tag, das niemand von uns wird vergessen. Das ist der Tag unserer Befreiung.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Um drei Uhr fünf und vierzig (3 Uhr 45) ....
David Boder: Am Tag oder Nacht?
Ludwig Hamburger: Am elften (11.) April, Tag – Nachmittag .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... ist der erste amerikanische Panzerwagen überschritten den Zaun in Buchenwald.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Freude ....... die kann man nicht beschreiben.
Ludwig Hamburger: Es ist unmöglich zu beschreiben. Die Soldaten .....
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... die gekämpft haben, die haben ..... nie gehabt Tränen, die haben ...... wie sie uns gesehen heben, da haben die geheult wie kleine Kinder.
David Boder: Welche Soldaten?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die amerikanischen Soldaten. Die haben sich niemals vorstellen können, dass hier ... jetzt ... in diesem Jahrhundert ... solche Sachen vorkamen. Die Menschen ... die Gesichter werde ich nie vergessen. Sie waren voll mit Staub, nur die Zähne und die Augen haben heraus geschaut. Wie sie uns gesehen haben, haben sie geweint. Sie haben genommen jeden von uns in den Arm und geküsst und sie haben uns alles gegeben. Einer hat sich die Jacke ausgezogen und hat gesehen, einer hat keine Jacke und hat sie raus genommen. Sie haben nie angenommen, dass so etwas passiert – hier in Deutschland, bei Weimar – eine der kul ... kulturellsten Stadt von Deutschland, dass man so was finden kann. Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann sind gekommen die Anderen.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie haben können nicht glauben, dass wir sind schon frei. Ich sah eine Frau .... sogar heute, wenn zu Hause ich bin und ich erinnere mich, dann sage ich mir – eines von den beiden ist unmöglich – träume ich jetzt oder war die Vergangenheit ein Traum?
David Boder: [In English] This concludes Spool number 72 (seventy two) recorded by Mr. Hamburger.
David Boder: [auf deutsch] Was ist ihr erster Name, Herr Hamburger?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ludwig.
David Boder: [in English] Ludwig. In Geneva at the Shops of the ORT. An Illinois Institute of Technology Recording.
David Boder: This is Spool 73 (seventy three). (Tapping noise) This is Spool 73 (seventy three) (Again tapping noise) Geneva, August the twenty sixth (26th). The interviewee is Ludwig Hamburger who finished just Spool 72. I will try to see if I can make him answer a few questions.
David Boder: [auf deutsch] Also, also sagen sie mir, Herr Hamburger, was haben Sie in Buchenwald den ganzen Tag getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Buchenwald sind wir morgens aufgestanden um sechs (6) Uhr; und Appell wird gemacht wie in jedem anderen Konzentrationslager und dann – nach dem Appell – an die Arbeit.
David Boder: Was haben Sie gearbeitet?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Buchenwald ist bekannt der Steinbruch.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir haben Stein geklopft, wir haben Steine getragen.
David Boder: Was hat man mit den Steinen gemacht?
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie haben .... sie haben gemacht damit den Straßenbau.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: In ganz Deutschland.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und dann war auch die Rüstungswerke.
David Boder: Ja. Mit was hat man Steine geklopft? Hat man Hammer gehabt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Werkzeug haben sie uns gegeben.
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie waren – ganz in der Nähe von Buchenwald – waren die großen Rüstungswerke.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Da sind auch Teile für die V-1 (V-eins) gemacht worden.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Dort haben viele, viele Häftlinge gearbeitet – unter Aufsicht und strenger Kontrolle der SS Männer und Meister, Capo, Vorarbeiter und so weiter.
David Boder: Und dann, nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Arbeit ist bestanden größtenteils von Transport, das heißt: Eisen tragen.
David Boder: Transport, Eisen tragen und?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und Verbindung zwischen Maschinen, das heißt Transport von einem Teil der Maschine zu der Anderen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Arbeit war schwer, verantwortlich und sehr unter scharfer Kontrolle.
David Boder: Warum war sie verantwortlich?
Ludwig Hamburger: Weil es war ..... wir haben gearbeitet an die Teile für die V-1.
David Boder: Aha, V-1 (V-one – Dr. Boder sagt es in englisch), nicht?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und wenn es nur eine Schraube .... eine Schraube hat gefehlt oder war nicht richtig angezogen – und das könnte machen ein Arbeiter – ein deutscher Arbeiter - ......
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: .... dann ist die ganze Schuld übertragen geworden auf die Häftlinge.
David Boder: Ja? (klopft mit dem Mikrophone)
Ludwig Hamburger: Und als Sabotage betrachtet und ...... Todesstrafe.
David Boder: Was heißt Todesstrafe? Wieso? Hat man ihn zu Gericht gebracht oder was?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, die SS Männer haben sich selber ein Gericht gemacht. Er ist einfach ins Lager gebracht geworden und ..... Torturen ....
David Boder: Was?
Ludwig Hamburger: Torturen.
David Boder: Was ist das?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ge.... ge .... Gepeinigt.
David Boder: Oh, oh, er wurde gefoltert, gepeinigt, ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Geschlagen, man hat ihn hängen lassen von ..... man hat ihn also gebunden an einen Baum, die Hände .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... und hat ihn zehn Stunden hängen gelassen.
David Boder: Haben Sie das gesehen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich bin einmal zwei Stunden selber gehangen dort.
David Boder: Wie sind Sie gehangen?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Auschwitz?
David Boder: Ich meine wieso?
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie haben mir die Hände von unten gebunden ......
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... und dann ganz langsam mit dem Strick hoch gezogen. Die Ende haben einen Ring gemacht.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und zwei Stunden bin ich gehangen.
David Boder: Und wie hoch waren Ihre Hände?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein .... also, also der Sinn des Ganzen ist gewesen, dass die Beine fünf Zentimeter (5 cm) entfernt sollen sein vom Fußboden.
David Boder: Oh, fünf Zentimeter (5 cm) vom Erdboden.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wenn sie haben gesehen, dass die Knochen haben sich ausgezogen .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... dann haben sie ihn etwas höher gezogen. So wir haben gefühlt – man kann sagen – den Fußboden unter uns.
Ludwig Hamburger: Aber wir konnten nicht stehen auf.
David Boder: Hm, also Ihre Füße haben den Fußboden nicht berührt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Fünf Zentimeter (5 cm) über dem Fußboden.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Also wenn ich wie auf der Spitze gestanden bin, da habe ich fünf Zentimeter (5 cm) unter mir bis zum Fußboden gehabt.
Ludwig Hamburger: Vom Fußboden.
David Boder: Und sie haben den Fußboden nicht berührt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein, nein!
David Boder: Nein. Nun wofür hat man das getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Deutschland schon für die kleinste Kleinigkeit – für nicht ‚Guten Tag’ zu sagen in Auschwitz. Auch in Buchenwald habe ich vielmals das Selbe durch gemacht. Ich gehe vorüber an einem SS Mann, ich geh auf die Mitte ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich bleibe stehen. Dann ruft er mich zu ihm und fragt mich: „Ah, bist Du mein Freund?“ Ich gib ihm keine Antwort. Dann schlägt er mich. Das nächste Mal – sag ich, da will ich nicht die Hütl runter ziehen. Und ich geh bei ihm vorbei und ich zieh nicht herunter die Hütl. Da ruft er mich wieder: “Weißt Du nicht, dass Du musst Dein Hütl abziehen?“ So, dass ich nicht wusste, was zu machen.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und so war’s mit allem ..... tagtäglich.
David Boder: Sie sagen, man hat Sie für zwei Stunden auf den Arm aufgehängt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun ja, wo haben Sie den Schmerz gefühlt? Wo hat man das?
Ludwig Hamburger: Also ....
David Boder: In die Schultern?
Ludwig Hamburger: In die Schulter.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und hier in der Verbindung ... wie heißt das?
David Boder: Ellbogen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Im Ellbogen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und an den Händen da.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und im Haupt.
David Boder: In die Augen?
Ludwig Hamburger: In die Haupt!
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Der Atem, ich konnte atmen nicht.
David Boder: Sie konnten nicht atmen, ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Alles war umgedreht und ich .... und nach unten waren die Hände gezogen ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... nicht nach vorne, deshalb .....
David Boder: Wer hat das getan? Warum und wofür hat man das getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: Hm, also .....
David Boder: In Ihrem Fall?
Ludwig Hamburger: In meinem Fall da habe ich meinem Freund bei der Arbeit was sagen wollen ....
David Boder: Aha.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... und ich habe es ihm gesagt. Und da hat mich ein Meister angeklagt und gesagt, ich arbeite nicht. Ich hab ihm nur gesagt: „Pass auf!“
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und nur für das einzige Wort hat man mich zwei (2) Stunden hängen gelassen bei den Händen.
David Boder: Waren da Andere in solchen Umständen zur selben Zeit?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, es waren tagtäglich welche (unverständlich). Es war ein Zimmer mit Haken hinein gehauen.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Da waren ungefähr fünfzehn Haken. Und an jedem Tag waren die Haken besetzt.
David Boder: Ja. Und wer hat das getan?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die SS.
David Boder: Die SS, nicht die Capos?
Ludwig Hamburger: Die Capos unter der Aufsicht der SS, die haben es, die SS Mann sind dort gestanden. Die haben es ... die größte Freude gehabt, wenn sie wussten, dass Einer, dass er bekommen wird Schläge oder man wird ihm was machen. Da sind sie alle gekommen und haben geschaut und gelacht ... es war das Schönste ... das Schönste für sie.
David Boder: Ah hm, nun also Sie haben in Buchenwald gearbeitet?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir dies, haben Sie Briefe schreiben können?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Buchenwald darf man Briefe schreiben, dreißig (30) Worte.
David Boder: Zu wem haben Sie geschrieben?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich habe überhaupt nicht geschrieben.
David Boder: Warum?
Ludwig Hamburger: Weil ich wusste, dass die Briefe waren unter starker Kontrolle. Wenn man schreibt, dann musste man schreiben „Es geht mir gut.“
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: „Es fehlt mir nichts.“
Ludwig Hamburger: „Ich brauche nichts, ich bin zufrieden.“
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Diese Briefe wollte ich niemandem schreiben.
David Boder: Und zu wem hätten Sie geschrieben?
Ludwig Hamburger: Also ... Familie ... oder Freunde.
David Boder: Haben Sie irgendwelche Briefe von Ihrer Familie bekommen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein.
David Boder: Sagen Sie, was waren Ihre Eltern Beschäftigung in Sosnowice ..... Katowicze?
Ludwig Hamburger: In Katowitz.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Mein Vater hat eine Fabrik gehabt.
David Boder: Also Katowitz war in der alten Zeit Deutschland und dann ist .....
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: .... es Polen geworden.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, Polen.
David Boder: Was für eine Fabrik hat Ihr Vater gehabt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Baubeschlag.
David Boder: Was ist das?
Ludwig Hamburger: Also Baubeschlag .... Metallteile für die Montage eines Hause.
David Boder: Ja. Und haben Sie Brüder und Schwestern gehabt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Eine Schwester.
David Boder: Und wo ist die?
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie ist zusammen mit die Eltern nach Auschwitz gebracht worden und seit damals hab ich keine Nachricht.
David Boder: Also keine Nachricht bekommen. Nun sagen Sie, was tun Sie jetzt in der Schweiz? Also wie sind Sie aus Buchenwald weg gekommen, wieso sind Sie in der Schweiz?
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann ist gekommen eine Kommission nach Buchenwald ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... von dem .... vom Schweizerischen Roten Kreuz .....
Ludwig Hamburger: .... und die haben genommen die Jugendlichen nach der Schweiz zur Erholung.
David Boder: Zur Erholung, ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir sind ungefähr 300 Jungs ......
David Boder: Jungen, ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ... von Buchenwald nach der Schweiz gebracht worden .....
David Boder: Um zu erholen. Und was dann?
Ludwig Hamburger: Und hier in der Schweiz wir haben sich erholt. Wir sind ....
David Boder: Wo haben Sie gelebt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir würden ... wir sind gebracht worden nach Reinfelden.
David Boder: Ja. Und wer hat Sie verpflegt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Also ich weiß es nicht genau, denn wir haben die Schweizer Pflegerinnen ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... die sich ...
Ludwig Hamburger: Und dann sind wir gebracht worden in noch andere Heime.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Und man hat uns gezeigt das Leben von einer ganz anderen Seite, als wir bis jetzt haben mitgemacht haben.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie wollten uns zeigen ..... sie haben sich große Mühe gegeben, uns zu zeigen, wie wirklich das Leben schaut aus .....
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... uns zu zeigen, wie man aufführen darf sich in Gesellschaft. Und Kameradschaft haben sie uns gezeigt und Familie.
David Boder: Nun?
Ludwig Hamburger: Dann sind wir gekommen nach Genf.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Also, ich bin ....
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich bin gekommen nach Genf .....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: .....und zu diesen ORT Schulen.
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich wusste Eines. Jetzt, wenn ..... nach allem was ich habe mitgemacht und obwohl ich bin sehr jung ......
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: .... weiß ich doch, dass jeder Mensch muss arbeiten, um zu leben. Und wir speziell.
David Boder: Wen meinen Sie mit „wir“?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir, die haben so viel durch gemacht.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wir wissen, dass niemals .... und wir verlangen auch niemals, dass man uns was schenken. Wir sind jung und wir sind stark, stark, weil wir haben das alles durch gemacht. Und wir wollen sich unsere Existenz selber bauen. Wir können schätzen Arbeit und wir wissen ganz genau, dass Lernen wichtig ist. Wir müssen nachfolgen weil längste Zeit, die wir haben verbracht in den Konzentrationslagern. Wir sind wild raus gekommen von die Konzentrationslager, wie wilde Tiere. Wir wussten einfach in die ersten Tage nicht, nicht wie auf der Strasse sich zu bewegen. Wir waren sechs (6) Jahre geschlossen hinter einem elektrischen Zaun, immer unter Prügel, immer mit der Angst, dass man uns ohne Grund erschießt. Langsam hat man sich gewöhnt an die neue Atmosphäre, die wir sind reingeschritten. Dann hab ich mir gesagt, ich muss ein – ich muss mich einen Beruf erlernen, um meine weitere Existenz zu erwerben. Ich habe angefangen zu suchen, ich habe mich freiwillig beworben. Ich habe ein Gesuch gemacht, eine Bitte ...
David Boder: Worauf?
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... an ORT.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... mich aufzunehmen.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Sie haben mich aufgenommen.
David Boder: Und was lernen Sie jetzt?
Ludwig Hamburger: Jetzt lerne ich hier in Genf, ORT, Mechaniker.
David Boder: Sie lernen Mechaniker?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Und wie lange wird das dauern bis Sie Mechaniker werden?
Ludwig Hamburger: Es dauert ..... der Kurs dauert zwei und ein halbes (2 ½ ) Jahr.
David Boder: Zwei und ein halbes (2 ½ ) Jahr. Und dann wohin denken Sie zu gehen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich hab mir Eines gesagt, .....
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: ..... ich möchte meinen Beruf können.
David Boder: Hm.
Ludwig Hamburger: Das Erste und das Wichtigste ist und das in die Hände zu haben. Wir wissen ganz genau – ein Mensch, der kennt nichts, der ist nichts. Wir müssen .... lernen alle einen Beruf ...
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: ... um weiter eine Existenz aufzubauen.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir einmal, hm, waren da welche Gedichte oder Lieder in Buchenwald?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja.
David Boder: Kennen Sie noch die Gedichte von Buchenwald?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein, aber ein Lied kann ich.
David Boder: Also wollen Sie jetzt ein bisserl singen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich ..... ich bin nicht, ich kann nicht so gut singen!
David Boder: Nein, Sie brauchen es nicht laut zu singen (unverständlich) ..... nur dass man die Worte klar hört, ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: [singt] Wenn der Tag erwacht /Und die Sonne lacht /Und Kolonnen ziehn / Untertags dahin / Schon in den grauen Morgen / Und der Wald ist schwarz / Und der Himmel rot / Und wir tragen im Rock / Nur ein Stückchen Brot / Und im Herzen, im Herzen die Sorgen / Oh Buchenwald – ich kann dich nie vergessen / Weil du nur gibst (unverständlich) / Weil ich, ich kann es erst ermessen / (unverständlich) / Oh Buchenwald, wir weinen nicht und klagen / Und was zu uns du hast getan / Wir wollen trotzdem ja zum Leben sagen / Denn einmal kommt der Tag / Dann sind wir frei / Wir wollen trotzdem ja zum Leben sagen / Denn einmal kommt der Tag / Dann sind wir frei.
David Boder: Hat die SS gehört, dass Sie das gesungen haben?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein!
David Boder: Wann haben Sie es gesungen?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nach der Befreiung.
David Boder: Hat man das nach der Befreiung gemacht?
Ludwig Hamburger: Nein, das war das Lied von Buchenwald. Wir haben ..... die SS Männer wussten ganz genau ....
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Aber die Wörter haben wir geändert nach der Befreiung. Zum Beispiel, die letzten Worte: „Es kommt der Tag, wo wir dann frei sind.“
David Boder: Und was war es bevor?
Ludwig Hamburger: Bevor war es .... ich erinnere mich nicht ganz gut.
David Boder: Hm. Erinnern Sie sich etwas an jüdische Lieder von Auschwitz oder mehr?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ja, ganz Viele.
David Boder: Ja, probieren Sie Eines. Ich möchte ..... erinnern Sie sich an das Lied..... „es brennt?“
Ludwig Hamburger: Ein Moment.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Ich kann ein Lied von ...... Aussiedlung.
David Boder: Ja.
Ludwig Hamburger: Wenn sie uns haben auf Transport geschickt.
David Boder: Ja?
Ludwig Hamburger: Wenn wir sind nach Hause gekommen, alleine, ohne Eltern, da haben wir es gesungen.
David Boder: All right!
Ludwig Hamburger: [singt – teilweise Jiddisch] Ohne ein Daheim und ohne ein Dach / Gewandert sind wir ein ganze Nacht / Nicht gewisst, wie, wohin / Was wird sein (unverständlich) / Weil ohne Daheim und ohne End / (unverständlich) / Im Wald, im Forst (unverständlich) / (unverständlich) und wir sind nicht geblieben / Angeringelt (unverständlich) / Mit Stöcken aus Holz uns geschlagen / Und (unverständlich) / Die Kinder schreien: „Mutter! Ich bin hungrig“ / Und die Mama haben kein Brot dafür gehabt / Oh je (unverständlich) Oh je / Weil ohne Daheim und ohne ein Dach / gewandert sind wir ein ganze Nacht / nicht gewisst, wie, wohin / Was wird sein (unverständlich) / Weil ohne Heim und ohne Dach / Wir sind gewandert die ganze Nacht.
David Boder: [In English] This concludes the interview with Mr. Ludwig Hamburger at Geneva, August the 26th, 1946 at the ORT School. An Illinois Institute of Technology wire recording.